Hela, the Goddess of Death
has invaded Asgard
Oh, I've missed this!
You and I had a fight
Did I win?
No, I won. Easily.
(Bruce) That doesn't sound right
(Thor) Well, it's true
(Announcer) Journey to a whole new world
of entertainment
and upgrade to the ultimate movie experience in
Cinemark XD
What were you the god of again?
Thor Ragnarok November 3rd in Cinemark XD
So much has happened since I last saw you
Lost my hammer, like, yesterday
so that's still pretty fresh
Then I went on a journey of self-discovery.
Where I met you
Where are we?
You have no idea
Hela, the Goddess of Death
has invaded Asgard
Oh, I've missed this!
And you and I had a fight recently
Did I win?
No, I won. Easily.
(Bruce) That doesn't sound right
(Thor) Well, it's true
Asgard is dead
And it will be reborn in my image
I thought you'd be glad to see me
We need to stop her here and now
to prevent Ragnarok: the end of everything
So I'm putting together a team
like the Old Days
Surprise!
This is gonna be such fun
Hello
Hi
He's a fighter
Here we go
I'm not a queen or a monster.
I'm the Goddess of Death
What were you the God of again?
We're the same, you and I.
Just a couple of hotheaded fools.
Yes, same. Hulk like fire.
Thor like water
Well, we're kinda both like fire
But Hulk like raging fire
Thor like smoldering fire